this morning Russian President Vladimir
Putin delivered a defiant message to the
West on the war in Ukraine on a day
marking the Allies victory in World War
II now his speech came just hours after
the Russian military fired a new barrage
of missiles at Ukrainian cities Charlie
dagada has more on that part of the
story
is an annual military Flex across Red
Square that's taken on added
significance since Russia launched its
invasion of Ukraine commemorating the
anniversary of the defeat of Nazi
Germany in 1945 but from Putin's
perspective it's now Russia that's under
attack from the West
a real war has once again been Unleashed
against our motherland he said
[Music]
surveying rows of young men who haven't
yet been sent to the slaughter on the
battlefields of Ukraine the president's
pleased expression belied the Grim
reality of his special military
operation
and even rolling out the big guns it was
a smaller display than previous parades
with a significant amount of Russia's
Firepower deployed elsewhere moscow's
attempt to rain missiles down on Ukraine
fell short with the Ukrainian Air Force
saying its defenses shot down 23 of 25
cruise missiles the majority once again
aimed at the capital itself that
followed a swarm of dozens of drones the
night before the largest drone attack
since the War Began we're told and it's
the fifth time Russia has tried to
attack the capital this month for CBS
mornings Charlie dagada Keith